so thank you for being here this evening
this conversation about black holes and
you know you'll find online that
Einstein himself is often quoted as
having said that black holes are what
happens when God divides by zero he
never said that he couldn't have the
phrase black holes was coined about 10
years after Einstein died but poetically
that's actually a fairly good way of
describing what it is that's gonna be
the focus here tonight because dividing
by zero is a it's a very extreme
mathematical operation right and black
holes are a very extreme physical object
in the universe and what we'd like to do
here tonight is of course you know start
gently get everybody up to speed and
then take us right to the frontier of
understanding these real gargantuan
monsters of the universe now to get
there your number of ways that you can
think about black holes but one nice way
in to the subject is to think about
something that's much more familiar
thinking about escape velocity let me
describe what I mean through a couple of
sequences here so imagine that you are
on the surface of the earth so let's
sort of zoom down right to our planet
and we ask ourselves if we fire a
projectile from the surface of the earth
upward what will happen and we all
pretty much know what will happen right
so if we take a cannon and we fire a
cannonball at a fairly modest speed it's
going to go up it's going to come back
down if we fire it with a somewhat
larger speed it'll go up higher but
still it'll come back down but finally
if we launch it with the right speed it
will go up and it will just barely
escape the gravitational pull of the
earth and it will go off into space and
that speed required for that to happen
is what we call escape velocity at the
surface
of the earth now what is the escape
velocity at the surface of the earth
yeah if someone actually said it was
11.2 km/s thank you Wow a gold star in
the back there about 11 kilometers per
second is what you needed to surface the
earth but here's the question if you
were to look at a different planet one
that's bigger than the earth what will
happen well again you can pretty much
picture what will happen if it's bigger
it's more massive you're going to need a
bigger cannon to fire that cannonball
with higher speed because the escape
velocity will go up it'll be larger than
it is at the surface of the earth but of
course if you have that big cannon you
actually fire it the Cannonball will go
up and again if its speed is bigger than
escape velocity it will be able to get
away but now I want you to think about
something a little bit less familiar
imagine that this cannon is not firing
cannon balls but it's firing balls of
light photons now light goes really
quickly right I mean light speed what
does this be the light above example
yeah everybody uses different units
which is nice 671 million miles per hour
300 million comments per second right
and meters per second I should say so at
that high speed of course light will
easily be able to escape and be able to
go off into space but here's the
interesting thought experiment and this
is a thought experiment that goes way
back this is an experiment that this
fella over here John Michell this is in
the 1700s right long time ago he asked
the following question he said look what
if you were to imagine looking at say a
star like the Sun now clearly the escape
velocity at the surface of the Sun is
much less than the speed of light so
certainly all the light that the Sun
emits easily gets away but just as the
escape velocity of a planet goes up if
you make it bigger more massive he asked
well the same should happen for a star
so let's imagine making the star bigger
where the escape velocity goes up now if
it's still less than the speed of light
the light will get away but he asked
what would happen if you made the star
so big that the escape velocity at its
surface would be bigger than the speed
of light right in that case he imagined
that if you made that gigantically
massive star light could not get away
the escape velocity would be bigger than
the speed of light and if light doesn't
get away the star would go dark a Dark
Star now this is again in the 1700s
right so he is thinking purely in a
Newtonian framework that's the only
description of gravity that we had back
then so the natural question is is this
musing of John Mitchell right this
theologian this natural philosopher from
the 18th century does this idea have
relevance when you start to think about
gravity in the manner that was given to
us by this fellow over here Albert
Einstein because I think as we all know
in the early years of the 20th century
Einstein rethought our understanding of
gravity and he gave us the general
theory of relativity in which gravity is
now thought of in a completely new way
not the Newtonian description gravity is
thought of as warps and curves in the
fabric of space and time so Einstein
takes this idea this new way of thinking
about gravity he writes his famous paper
on the general theory of relativity this
is in 1915 his paper becomes widely
circulated and indeed about a year later
1916 on the Russian front there's a
German astronomer mathematician named
Karl Schwarzschild and he's out there in
the trenches charged with calculating
artillery trajectories and somehow just
by coincidence what happens is Einsteins
paper just kind of goes by
he grabs ahold of it and he gets so
captivated by Einsteins ideas that he
forgets about artillery trajectories and
starts to calculate with general
relativity he finds that if you have a
spherical body that you crush down to a
very small size according to Einstein's
math the warp in the fabric of space
would be so extreme that nothing can
pull away not even light can pull away
so it's now a modern day version if you
will of what John Michell had imagined
an object that goes black because light
cannot pull away from it so roughly
speaking it would be as if you had a
flashlight near the edge of one of these
objects and when you turn on the light
instead of a light going off into space
like it's pulled down into the hole into
the black hole this is the modern-day
version of what a black hole would be
now the term black hole it turned out
this was coined on 112 Street and
Broadway I'm not joking
at the Goddard Institute of Space
Studies on 112 in Broadway John Wheeler
was given a talk and this way of
describing these dark stars came up and
wheeler pushed this idea he popularized
this a he advanced our understanding of
it but this is where the term black hole
comes from now this of course is a sort
of cartoon version that gets at the
basic idea for those that want to see it
a little bit more precisely here's
really what goes on near the vicinity of
a black hole and if you don't understand
this it doesn't matter we can put down a
spacetime diagram if you remember from
high school this is where we have time
on this vertical axis and you set off a
beam of light that fills out a cone
so-called light cone and what happens is
the geometry of space and time is so
distorted by a black hole that beyond
what's called the event horizon the
direction of time and space is so
twisted that as light propagates it
cannot get out of the edge
it cannot go beyond the event horizon of
the black hole and that's why no light
can get out that's why the black hole is
black now natural question is okay these
are interesting ideas but how in the
world would one of these objects come to
be and people began to think about this
idea for a long time 30s 40s 50s and let
me give you one possible scenario by
which the kind of object we're looking
at a black hole would form and for that
we can imagine that we have a large star
like a red giant to support its
incredible weight this star has nuclear
processes taking place in the core that
generate heat and light and pressure
that props the star up but sooner or
later the star uses up all of its
nuclear fuel and at that point it can't
support its own weight so it begins to
implode and as it implodes it gets
hotter and denser finally setting off an
explosion that ripples through the star
and when the explosion reaches the
surface of the star it causes the outer
layers to explode and what remains if
the star was big enough to begin with is
a tiny core a dense core that can no
longer support its own weight at all and
it will collapse all the way down into
one of these objects these black holes
that's the idea of how these objects
could form and what we'd like to do here
tonight is explore our current thinking
about these objects are they real how
would we actually see them and can we
get any insight into what happens inside
of these spectacular objects and to do
that we are going to bring out some
experts who spent their careers
examining these very questions and let's
get to them right now so our first guest
is one of the world's leading experts in
observational astrophysics who heads
UCLA's galactic center group best known
for a groundbreaking insights on the
center of our galaxy
she's the winner of among other things
the Crawford prize in astronomy from the
Royal Swedish Academy of Science Anna
MacArthur Fellow
please welcome Andre agos
all right also joining us is an
astronomer at the harvard-smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics who leads an
international collaborative project
called the event horizon telescope whose
goal is to image the edge the event
horizon of a black hole so please
welcome Shep dollar mark
[Music]
all right so thank you both for joining
us here tonight let me just begin with
sort of one general question so people
have been thinking about this idea of
black holes for a long time as I said
all the way back in the 1700s and a lot
of research has been done thousands of
pages of calculations do you think that
there are really black holes out there
or our theorist imaginations overworked
I think it's pretty clear that there are
black holes out there of course I'm a
little biased since you spent your life
trying to observe them yes that's it
think about the fact that there are two
kinds of black holes yes black holes
that you were just talking about the
ones that come from the lifespan of
stars and then the supermassive black
holes that we think are at the center of
the galaxy and those are the ones that
you've actually been studying in some
detail so that we're gonna get to those
in just a moment but Shep your general
view is more or less the same or do you
think there's a chance that it's a red
herring that these black things are not
really out there
oh no it's beyond a shadow of a doubt I
really think they exist I mean there's
all these lines of evidence you know we
see these terrifying engines the Centers
of galaxies that spew out these Jets on
either side of them and the only thing
that can power them are supermassive
black holes so everything is pointing to
the fact that these really do exist good
so I'm glad you're saying that because
had you both said no I don't know what
we do with the rest of our time here
today but that's great so so Andreea
your work as I understand it has been
focused on the center of the Milky Way
galaxy so first of all just just give us
some sense of what you think is residing
in the center of our galaxy and then
we'll try to look at the evidence that
led you to come to that conclusion so we
are pretty convinced that there's a
supermassive black hole at the center of
our galaxy and how do you go Superman
when we say supermassive we mean a
million - well in the case of our own
galaxy four million times the mass of
the Sun and in terms of these really big
ones that are at the center of galaxies
that's on the low end because we think
about things that are a million to a
billion times the mass of the Sun and
for a million solar mass block
like how like for the Sun let's maybe we
start simple if the Sun was turned into
a black hole how what would its radius
be it would be about the size of college
campus no it depends which college
you're talking about good so so a couple
kilometers across for the one in the
center of the galaxy how big do we think
it is it's about ten times the size of a
sudden so about ten mil 10 million
kilometers Wow
so it's it's it's a big object but it
still follows the same basic pattern
that it has an edge and event horizon
and all the standard lore would apply to
it it's just on a bigger scale right it
just scales simply with math math yeah
so so so what evidence do you have that
it is a black hole can you sort of take
us through that yeah so to prove that
there's a black hole directly what you
want to do is you want to you want to
show that there's a lot of mass inside a
small volume or inside a small region in
particular you'd like to show that it's
confined within its short sheild radius
that you were just talking to our latest
is is the radius for a given mass where
if you can crush the mass within that
radius it will naturally turn into a
black hole right and so that's what
we're the size that we're talking about
because of course the black hole itself
is infinitesimally small so this this
isn't that the abstract size and so our
job just clarify that so when you say
that you're talking about when the black
hole forms the matter crushes down to a
small size yeah so the idea of the
Schwarzschild radius or is that no light
can escape it as we were just talking
about but it's also true that once you
get the mass to that scale gravity will
overcome all other known forces and
there's nothing that can stop the
collapse of the object so from a
scientific point of view once you've
shown that a mass is within its
Schwarzschild radius you have come up
with for the proof of a black hole so
from the point of view of somebody who's
hunting for black holes your
job is to show that there's some amount
of mass inside a small volume so the way
we've approached it at the center of the
galaxy is to look for the stars that are
at the heart of the galaxy and to
develop techniques that allow us to not
only see the stars that are that close
but that allow us to observe how they go
around the center so if you want to find
the center of the galaxy you can look up
in the night sky and find the
constellation of Sagittarius it's the
teapot and the teapot pours into the
center of the galaxy all right that's
your road is so convenient and if you
look up at the night sky not in of
course New York but in a place that you
can actually see the night sky you can
see the Milky Way and the Milky Way is
that band of white light that comes from
the Stars but there's also a lack of
light which is from all the dust so you
can't actually see the center of the
galaxy at wavelengths at your eye
detects so a key to the work that we've
done is to use infrared technology so
looking at light that is just long word
of what your eye detects maybe we're a
TV remote control works yep and that
allows us to see the stars that are at
the center of the galaxy and we'll have
you found and we've found that they go
or one that we can see them which is
rather amazing and that they go around
the center of the galaxy quite fast so
those my favorite star in the galaxy
it's name is so2 goes around every time
again
so2 okay probably needs a better name
yeah it's real catchy so if you have a
better name we'll leave it to the
audience to figure that out but you can
use actually Newton's laws of physics to
show that if you go around every 16
years and you measure the size of the
orbit which is about the size of our
solar system that shows that there's
about 4 million times the mass of the
Sun inside this incredibly small region
and and to give you a sense of the
change of our knowledge over our
understanding of what resides at the
center of the galaxy we've increased the
density of dark matter by a factor of
ten million compared to what was known
before artwork so in a sense we've we've
advanced the case for the existence of
supermassive black holes by that amount
may think about anything in your life
that you'd like more of and being able
to get ten million times more of right
and that's what's happened at the center
right so the basic argument as I
understand it is you're tracking these
stars and their motion can only be
explained if there is a black hole of
that mass residing in the center of the
galaxy you're basically weighing this
what's at the center there was this
actual data this is the real thing so
we've looked at two versions of it one
is the flat version which was show uh
was playing just a moment ago and and it
showed my favorite star and this is
actually a bigger view of the data that
we took that we've taken over the last
and I can't believe I'm saying this
twenty-five years have you been involved
with it maybe I shouldn't ask oh yeah
this is my been since the beginning this
is I mean this is my baby it is so in
fact it's uh it's interesting to reflect
back because when I first proposed this
experiment when I first got my job at
UCLA I thought I had a good idea it was
actually turned down
they said the technique wouldn't work
and even if it did we wouldn't see stars
and even if we saw stars we wouldn't see
them move so it was a lotta no no no's
right and in fact we were asking to do a
project that was only three years long
just to see that stars were moving fast
no one anticipated that they were moving
they would move so fast how fast is fast
just to give it oh oh like three million
miles an hour
so they're they're hauling and it's and
it's rather remarkable that we can
measure something on a human time scale
and so as this project has gone on and
maybe we can talk a little later about
you know what it takes the technology
has changed so much that it's enabled us
to do more and more sophisticated kinds
of work so this three dimensional
animation actually shows the kinds of
stars that we see at the center of the
galaxy and almost every single
prediction for what we should see near
the black hole is inconsistent with the
observations what does that mean that
means it's job security you're trying to
figure it out yeah but but it's not
inconsistent yet with say the general
relativistic prediction no so there's
both the physics side of this work where
you're trying to ask physics questions
like do supermassive black holes exist
how does gravity work near a
supermassive black hole so the where we
are today is that we can definitive or
at least in my opinion we can
definitively say that the supermassive
black hole exists and then the where we
are actually we are so in the middle of
this can we test Einstein's theory of
general relativity and that is what your
you're doing now if I understand like
we're actually a special time at this
very moment right yes we're in such a
special moment I can't believe I'm
actually sitting here as opposed to
being in Hawaii thank you for taking the
time with but tell us tell us what's
going on so the reason I'm so excited
and we've been preparing for this for
years
so we've been doing wait there's no
chance you're gonna miss like the
special moment but I have grad students
so we've been using the Keck telescopes
which are pictured here for 25 years and
watching the star that goes around every
16 years and if you want to test
Einstein's theory of general relativity
near supermassive black hole with these
stars what you have to do is first make
your first go around that gives you a
baseline of what what part of space
these stars are probing and that's 16
years right there that's 16 years right
there my various moments in my life
around the star and then what you want
to do is you want to catch it the next
time it goes through closest approach
and that next time was the year 2018 so
I've been thinking 2018 or bust for a
number of years so we're in it we're in
this season and for us there really is a
season because the earth goes around the
Sun so and because we're looking at
infrared light you're gonna hear from
Shep there are different kinds of light
so Shep doesn't care
[Laughter]
because the earth goes around the Sun
there's only a part of the year that we
can see the center of the galaxy at
infrared wavelengths so for me we can
see it from roughly March to roughly
October so there was the beginning of
the season and through these roughly six
months this star is experiencing
incredible accelerations and is
experiencing the most extreme forms of
gravity as it makes its closest approach
so actually there are three key moments
one that happened April 10th one that
happened roughly last week and one
that's happening in September that are
going to nail down this experiment so it
is it's an exciting moment for us and to
see the signal emerge from the data it's
it's just a treat so if I understand
correctly have a prediction based on the
general theory of relativity what the
trajectory should be well here we have
to be a little bit careful because
there's a series of kinds of experiments
that you part me there's a series of
tests of gravity one is how the the
light from the star makes it from the
star to us in other words how it escapes
the curvature of space-time that's
actually the first thing that we're
getting at this summer the next thing is
then how the object itself moves through
space-time which is actually should
emerge over the next few years so again
and if you keep going and of course
that's what we want to do you can
actually measure the spin of the black
hole so this experiment just keeps
getting better right and and it's
particularly interesting I gather
because you know most people think that
Einstein's general relativity has been
confirmed but is that the right way of
thinking about it well it's uh you know
it's one of the gravity is one of the
four fundamental forces but oddly enough
it's the least tested of those forces so
it's been tested in some regimes but
it's never been tested near a
supermassive black hole and as some say
it's a supermassive black hole or black
holes and generals represent the
breakdown of this theory so what you
want to do is you want to get as close
as possible to the Hat point where you
actually know that theory is no longer
holding up and I think we have to have
today all sorts of pieces of evidence
that says this theory is fraying at the
edges so we just push that frontier
forward by a large amount in a direction
that hasn't been explored before so in
principle you could find the first
concrete evidence that we need to go
beyond Einsteins ideas to really
describe what's going on I mean the best
of all worlds that would be the outcome
of 16 plus years of observation well the
outcome is actually just figuring out
what's really happening your the black
hole whatever it is yeah yeah yeah it's
spectacular so Shep you you were also in
the business of looking at black holes
there's no business like black hole biz
no business like back over there and so
you're going about in a different way so
we're hearing about infrared light as
the probe being used to in andreas work
you're using what radio yeah we're using
radio waves it turns out that black
holes in a paradox of their own gravity
are some of the brightest things in the
sky right and that's because of a very
simple construct all the matte all the
gas and dust is trying to get into a
very small region so it heats up to
hundreds of billions of degrees around
Sagittarius a star the supermassive
black hole in the center of our galaxy
and it radiates in infrared that Andrea
looks at and also radio waves even
little bit in x-rays so if you want to
look at a black hole you can come at it
from many many different angles no no
critical to both of what you're saying
is you're not really looking at the
black hole you're looking at its effect
on its environment right so you can't
actually see it per se exactly what
happens in the black hole stays in the
black hole yeah let's just get that out
of the way right now but what we do is
we tease around the edges right so in
that cannonball analogy you had before
light was leaving the black hole but it
also orbits around the black hole just
think about that for a minute light
orbits something right and goes around
in a circle and Einstein 100 years ago
when he came up with this general theory
of relative
those equations show that you should see
the silhouette of light around the black
hole and that's because of these light
orbits around so we look at it and you
see light moving around the black hole
and it gets brighter on one side on the
other side you see something that should
be about five times the source or radii
across right you know how how big it
should be so the event horizon is here
you're looking at five times that
distance exactly exactly so you never
see inside the black hole but you see
outside and that shows us the geometry
of space-time when you see something
like this when you see this shadow
feature you're really looking at the
deepest puncture in space-time that we
can imagine right and the ground it's
actual have you is this what you guys I
mean can you share with us what you guys
have seen this is the event horizon
telescope I gather you're talking right
so they so the question is if you wanted
to zoom in by orders of many many
thousands and see what was happening
right the edge of a black hole you'd
have to go way beyond where aundrea sees
her stars and go much closer and those
stars are about a thousand times farther
out than this silhouette that you're
seeing here right and if we could
measure the size of the silhouette in
the shape we test Einstein's theory of
gravity right at the edge of the black
hole right now how are you doing that
there is a handful of radio telescopes I
gather yeah so to see something this
small these are the smallest objects in
the known universe right black holes are
tiny and to see them you need magnifying
power and as it is with all telescopes
the bigger the telescope the more
magnifying power you have now we can't
make a one huge telescope that sees
radio waves what we do is we install
atomic clocks had multiple radio dishes
around the world we record data and then
we play it back at a central facility
and we create a virtual telescope as big
as the earth ourselves if there's as big
as the earth itself these are some of
the people who who work on the on these
various places how many teams are there
well we have eight geographic locations
right now we're going to nine and then
ten the year after next and when you
stitch together all of these telescopes
you wind up getting a virtual dish
that's the size of the earth that is
exactly tuned it turns out to image the
supermassive black hole in the center of
our galaxy
and we've just taken some of the first
data from this event horizon telescope
one year ago and we're crunching on the
data now and what have you
what do you found I can't tell you oh
come on no it turns out that if you if
you really want to make one of these
images it takes a long time to calibrate
the data it's all about the details
a lot of people think that we just turn
this telescope on and we'll see
something immediately but it's you know
we're nerds at heart right and we just
love to get to the telescopes and find
all these details and it turns out that
you really have to run down every single
one of these possible sources of
contamination the data before you can be
sure that you've seen this kind of
shadow silhouette yeah you know we were
able to actually talk to a couple
members of the of the team who slipped
us actually some of the data I hope you
don't mind if we if we show it here you
show the show the this is actually I'm
understanding this is the the most
precise image ever of a black hole do we
do we have that can we bring the lights
down and show this is that is that
doable
yeah so so yeah all right there there
there it is very good yeah so think
that's good not for us thank you no so
um so uh you can look the real nervous
there for a second yeah so so when will
you be releasing I saw an article just a
couple of days ago which is kind of a
teaser it seemed like for a release of
data that's coming up is that soon and
no it'll probably be in the first part
of the 2019 2019 yeah because right now
we're crunching the data you know we
know that the event horizon telescope
worked so what we did was we also looked
at quasar supermassive black holes that
are really far away where basically
point sources and everything seems to
have worked perfectly technically on the
telescope so so we know that all the
systems are a go and then we turned all
the telescope swivel to look at
Sagittarius a star the supermassive
black hole in the center of our galaxy
and and we think everything is working
fine there but we're still crunching on
the data so and and the data I saw some
article that had come from the South
Pole and you had to wait for the
the winter to clear to fly that was that
the kind or yeah that's going on or well
so that the whole point as Andrea said
if you want to test Einstein's theory
you've got to go to the most extreme
points in the universe you've got to go
to the ultimate proving ground which is
the edge of a black hole and we have to
go to some pretty extreme places
ourselves right so we have teams that go
down to the South Pole we go to the tops
of extinct volcanoes where there are
radio dishes that do the work that we
want to do we go to Hawaii Mauna Kea
high desert plains and Chile and you go
up to these sites and it's really a bit
of a labor of love because all these
teams go there they work their hearts
out they capture data in this technique
that we use this event horizon telescope
technique is really the ultimate and
delayed gratification
all right go see here's what you do it
so what when Andre goes to our telescope
it's pretty straightforward from
conceptually the light bounces off a
paraboloid it goes to the focus that's
it right you get what you want right
there what happens with us is the light
hits one of our dishes it's stored
through high-speed instrumentation that
we've built over the last decade on hard
disks the same kind of hard disk that
you would get in your computer and they
stay there until they're brought back on
an airplane because nothing beats the
bandwidth of a 747 filled with distress
nothing ok even when I'm walking down
the hallway with two of these disks you
know I'm beating the fastest internet in
the world ok and we bring them back
together and the operation in this
supercomputer that we use is equivalent
to light bouncing off of a perfectly
shaped parabola joining in coherence
alright so we play it back together and
we adjust it back and forth until we get
it just right and that effectively turns
the earth into a parabola if you think
about that so all of this data has to
come back and if it's at the South Pole
it's in a deep freeze all right so we've
got to wait six months just to get that
data back right all right so that's one
of the delays that we've been faced not
just now you have done some simulations
of what you anticipate emerging from the
data looking at the magnetic field and
vicinity of a black hole can you take us
through some of the things that you
anticipate emerging from the study I
think we have some things up Serena so
what you're seeing here is the best
guess we have from your high speed
simulations of what you would see if you
had infinite
illusion goggles right so you wind up
seeing this this shadow feature the
circular feature with some jets leaving
from the North and South Poles and
that's because there are magnetic fields
right around the boundary of the black
hole there's relativistic particles
they're orbiting these magnetic fields
and they're releasing something called
synchrotron emission which is kind of a
characteristic radio emission you get
from these kinds of sources and it's so
bright in that synchrotron emission that
it shines out from the deepest part of
the gravity well right so you so think
about it everything has to go right it's
a Goldilocks situation you have to be
able to see through the Earth's
atmosphere and radio waves can do that
you've got to be able to see through the
distance between the earth and the
galactic center radio waves can
summarize that just to give people a
sense of it so it's about 25,000
light-years away good right so it's you
know this black hole is not threatening
to us we observe it it's nice so these
radio waves can go all the way to the
you know from the black hole but then
we're not done yet because it has to go
through the hot gas swirling around the
black hole right and then it has to go
all the way down into the gravity well
so it's a Goldilocks situation because
we meet all those criterion with radio
waves and it turns out that the earth
happens to be just the right size so
that when you look at radio waves with a
wavelength of one millimeter
they're perfectly tuned to take the
picture of Sagittarius a star that's it
with an earth-sized dish it was just a
resolution yeah so sometimes nature
throws us all these curve balls you know
what we can't do this or this is hard
this is one case where everything's
falling into place and so we really
think we have a good shot of taking a
the first image of a black hole and and
do you have a chance as well of finding
a deviation from the general theory of
relativity can this be viewed as another
extreme testing ground what we're
looking it's never a good idea to bet
against Einstein okay I don't make it a
point in my career to do it you know but
it is a trust but verify situation okay
I mean he's a he was a very smart guy
let's just put it that way
but every theory needs to be tested well
when you say he's a very smart guy that
true but he wasn't a great fan of this
idea of black holes at all right I mean
he kind of didn't think they were real
well well this out he was a little bit
off on that one right okay so he had one
bad moment but but this really speaks to
this kind of golden age that Dondre was
talking about with the event horizon
telescope where the observations are
being made by the Keck were really in
this discovery space for black holes and
we could be at the moment when we can
start to answer these questions like do
black holes exist was Einstein right at
the very black hole boundary I mean you
know you showed short child in the
trenches in World War one yeah you know
and he died later that year actually so
this was his last big discovery and he
wrote down the Schwarzschild metric and
he gave what the decay my space outside
of black the shape of space outside the
black hole and and now we're kind of
engaging in this handshake across 100
years where we're kind of completing
this circuit and we're saying you know
you made these intense predictions and
we're just at the point now where we
might be able to test them right and
that is extraordinary and and it speaks
to the fact that science is not linear
we don't go from point A to point B we
don't say we're gonna March and test
this it's very erratic and and that's
why Einstein felt black holes might not
exist it took a hundred years for them
to become part of our lexicon right
you're part of the reality of our
everyday conversation now do you do do
either of you or both of you as you're
working on your observational projects
do you have pet ideas or pet theories
about what the next phase beyond
Einstein might be or do you just
basically just go forward into the data
the observations and and that's the only
thing that's really driving you or do
you have a an idea of what might be the
next phase of this understanding of
gravity well well let me just take this
one second I'm a real I'm a realist I'm
kind of a craftsman at heart like I like
to go to the tops of mountains and make
observations I like to see what's around
the black hole right I can understand
and wrap my brain around the light
that's coming outside the event horizon
what's inside the event horizon you know
that's a question that is hard to even
ask you know little Otis asked it I
didn't order to answer it I did it's
easy to wonder out ya know but but but
for example one thing we're looking at
with the event horizon telescope is to
see if that silhouette is not round
ah what if it's distorted okay and if
it's distorted then we have some
framework of understanding how general
relativity itself might be violated to
give us those strange shapes so we're
betting on Einstein we're betting it's
going to be circular but if it's not we
have some ways of understanding what
might make it non circular yeah so we're
winding down to the end of our section
but Andre I want to ask you a question
which is how do you proceed in an era
when you might be going beyond ensign
when do you know that you're right when
when do you know that things have
coalesced to the point that you're
willing to make a statement of that sort
interesting an important question that
we're really the thick of because if you
see things that don't make sense you you
don't have a context you're you're kind
of air and you're exposed and you have
to convince yourself that what you're
seeing is physics as opposed to
experimental error right err err err so
III think there's a an interesting
philosophical point here about how do
you convince yourself you've got the
right answer yeah I mean there was an
interesting case with bicep2 oh yes a
few years ago where some have said that
they so knew what they were looking for
that they were biased in assessing what
the dad was telling them it's a classic
thing called confirmation bias so and
and this kind of work where we have such
a respect for Einstein and his ideas
that we go in with a premise that it
must be correct so it is interesting in
terms of how you actually design your
team's work to avoid getting a result
you believe to be true
and allowing your team to really trust
what the data is telling you so I think
that's a that that's certainly my goal
as a scientist to get to that point
where you're really just listening or
paying attention to the information that
might be unexpected but to try to remove
your your desire to have any particular
answer be it Einstein right or be it
Einstein wrong yep
just to be open to whatever the answer
truly is right yeah well I should say
you know all of us revere Einstein but
at the same time how thrilling would be
if either or both you find evidence that
we do need to go beyond the insights
that he gave us 100 years ago so we wish
you well and we'll have you back a year
or two maybe then you'll be able to give
us some insight into what you guys have
found so everybody please join me in
thanking our great guys Jeff : oh thank
you very much
in 1916 this is year after Einstein
wrote his paper on the general theory of
relativity Einstein continued to think
about the theoretical ideas and he wrote
a paper which we have here where he was
thinking about the possibility that if
space and time can warp and curve then
it might be the case that space and time
can also ripple right the image to have
in mind is think about trampoline right
a trampoline you put something heavy in
the middle it has a nice curvature to it
but if you have kids that are jumping
all around on the trampoline the shape
doesn't stay nice and static it ripples
it vibrates so he was wondering whether
it might be the case that space itself
might be able to undergo these kinds of
ripples these kinds of vibrations and
this would be known as a gravitational
wave now interestingly he wrote a first
paper in 1916 in 1918 he corrected an
error in the 1916 paper and it continued
to struggle with whether or not he
actually believed that gravitational
waves were a prediction of the general
theory of relativity and he worked on
this by himself he worked on it with
collaborators Nathan Rosen being one of
them and a couple years after this paper
where they expressed some confidence
that gravitational waves were real Rosen
writes another paper where he basically
says that he thinks they're all just a
mathematical artifact and I think many
historians think that Einstein himself
kind of had that view that the really
weren't these ripples in the fabric of
space and yet by the 1960s when the
mathematical methods had been refined
where we could really look at Einstein's
equations and extract from them the
actual physical predictions with
certainty it became clear that
gravitational waves were a prediction of
Einstein's theory which would mean
and that if you had say two objects like
two neutron stars rotating around they
would so disturb the environment that
they send out this train of
gravitational waves and that would mean
in principle you could detect these
because downstream if you're in the wake
of one of these gravitational waves you
will experience this kind of an effect
of stretching and squeezing and
stretching and squeezing now I should
say this animation is not to scale when
you actually do the calculation you find
that for a typical Astrophysical
phenomenon you'd find that the
stretching and squeezing would be less
than an atomic diameter so the question
is how could you ever measure something
so fine and yet as we'll discuss now
exactly that kind of a measurement has
been achieved and so to talk about that
let's turn to our next guest
and let me make sure that I'm able to
introduce her appropriately and I
believe I can do that now okay so
joining us to take a closer look at
gravitational wave has the lead
astrophysicist in the LIGO scientific
collaboration she is a distinguished
professor of physics and astronomy at
Northwestern please join me in welcoming
Vicki
Calogero
[Music]
so thank you for being here thank you
and we'd like to get some insight into
how gravitation waves have been detected
and LIGO is the facility so what is LIGO
Stanford LIGO like or is the double
acronym actually it stands for laser
interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory and laser itself is an
acronym
so it's a double acronym and what's that
acronym laser is such engrained in my
head I don't remember the full acronym
and I think occasion by stimulated
emission of radiation but I'm not sure
all right so okay so here's our detector
here's our our telescope our
gravitational wave telescope it's a new
type of telescope it doesn't look like
your traditional telescope does it so it
has this corner station where you can
see it there can we run that again yeah
thank you yes and and then it has these
tubes and it's like tubes of a regular
telescope except these are on the ground
and there are two of them and from the
corner station which should down lasers
in a triangle and they travel down these
four kilometer tubes vacuum tubes and
they reach the end they bounce off
mirrors and they come back and they we
study the light the laser light that
comes together and through the
interference pattern of the laser light
we can tell whether the mirrors at the
end of those arms are being shaken in
these squeezed and stretched squeezed
and stretch motion that gravitational
waves are supposed to affect space and
time but space is what we can think
about easier and you can actually
measure shaking by atomic distances in
fact it's even smaller than that it's
it's a smaller than one thousandth of
the nucleus on the scale of the four
kilometers
it's the most accurate measurement we
have ever achieved humans have ever
achieved anywhere in any field of
science or an engineering now how do you
know that the shaking is a gravitational
wave and like not someone just kicking
the equipment there's a lot of shaking
going on everywhere and that was the
reason why we didn't just build one of
these detectors we built two detectors
one in Louisiana State and one in
Washington really far away from one
another because if the shaking is
happening and it's affecting the one
detector and it's coincident I'm sorry
and it is earth-based then it's very
hard to reproduce the exact kind of
shaking the exact kind of squeezing and
stretching and have it happen in two
different locations independent
locations so far away
so having coincidence as we call it at
the same time with exactly the same
squeezing and stretching pattern it was
extremely important so we needed to be
able to claim such a an unprecedented
claim that we detected gravitational
waves it was really important to have
observations of the exact same signal at
the same time in two different
independent locations and this in this
first happiness was the first achieved
in 2015 got the world's a 40 well the
world didn't know on September 14 2015
some of us did and that was a
life-changing day for the hundreds of
scientists and engineers who are members
of the LIGO scientific collaboration the
world found out On February 11th 2016
when we made the first an announcement
and and so what was found so what was
found is that basically two black holes
one in orbit around the other were
disturbing space-time not very close to
us not at the center of our galaxy but
actually over a billion light
years away at some other galaxy and the
two black holes were coming together
because of the emission of gravitational
waves they were disturbing space-time
around them generating these ripples
that you talked about earlier and these
ripples were travelling for over a
billion years at the speed of light and
on September 14
they came approached the earth from the
south they hit our Louisiana detector
first and seven about seven millisecond
laters they hit our Washington State
detector second and that's what you
expected is that how long we take light
to travel that's naughty so there has to
be a finite delay because of course
gravitational waves just like light
doesn't travel instantaneously
it takes incidentally next time so the
two black holes as they were coming
together in their orbit losing energy
because of gravitational wave emission
at the end they merged like in this
other movie as well they emerged and
they I'll explain the sound in a minute
because it's not self-explanatory yes
not really not everybody gets it well I
did a version of this on Stephen Colbert
show and his interpretation is God Bugs
Bunny that that's how he should say
Stephen Colbert is a northwestern
undergraduate look at that and we have
talked about the graduation of discovery
so so the two black holes are coming
together and eventually they have
nowhere to go they're coming and they're
they're basically physically touching
except there is no actual surface there
is no hard surface that is that
imaginary surface where light can't
escape and the two black holes merge
into a single bigger black hole they
form a single black hole and then that
single bigger black hole settles and the
disturbance stops and the gravitational
wave signal stops so it's a finite
transient signal there is this whole
turmoil in space-time and by the time
you form the single signal
whole the whole thing ends now we talk
about the actual signature as shaking
these devices in Washington and
Louisiana by less than an atomic
diameter yeah but what was that signal
like when the black holes actually
collided way out there a billion um I
don't have that particular number for
you but it does scale as one over the
distance so if we take 1.3 for that
first detection if you take 1.3 billion
light-years away it was that many times
bigger when it was generated so I'm
calculating yes so that would be about
50 times the energy output of every star
in the observable you so so that's so
the basic lesson though is it's a huge
huge explosion or gravitational wave
energy for a very small amount of time
so the signal was 0.2 seconds and for
that 2 seconds when it that lasted
within our the frequency range that LIGO
the LIGO detectors are sensitive to so
you should think you heard about
electromagnetic waves and they come in
different frequencies our optical is the
optical frequency range infrared radio
waves etc these are all different
frequencies of the same type of wave
electromagnetic waves gravitational
waves have frequencies themselves so
like God can't see every single
gravitational wave out there can only
see frequencies between about 20 Hertz
to about now maybe hundreds of Hertz
let's say 700 of Hertz at best right so
in that frequency range this first
binary black hole collision lasted about
0.2 seconds right
in that short amount of time the
collision and energy generated in
gravitational waves outshined by a
factor of 50 all the light generated by
all the stars in the whole visible
universe not visible by eye but in the
whole universe that we know often we
could ever detect and it just dilutes as
it travels hey that's right yes so so
you know I've you know been asked about
this is such an amazing discovery that
you and your team I mean it's just it's
fantastic but how I'm watching can we
look at the data because I don't want to
ask you a question yeah so can you
actually go back to the sound by the way
that that's what I'm gonna come back
right now so can you bring up the actual
data of the of the two colliding black
holes do we have that up there
great yes can you bring up can you raise
the volumes I can't really hear it so
that's the tiny signature that you're
talking so you can just hold it up there
if you would so here's my a few things
please go ahead
well my general question is how can that
that little tiny window of data give you
so much insight into what the source was
yeah so that so I the reason is that
this scribble that we can see on the
screen and the banana that you can see
on the screen carries a lot of
information okay and I'll take a few you
know maybe a minute or two to explain it
first let me start by explaining the
significance of the sound okay I don't
want anybody in this room to have any
misunderstanding gravitational waves are
not sound waves okay so don't go away
telling anybody that gravitational waves
are sound waves however we can take the
frequencies remember I said something
about 20 Hertz to a few hundred Hertz if
you know something about music and the
frequency of sounds that are really
sensitive to that's about the range of
the frequencies of sound that our ear is
sensitive to so we can take the
gravitational wave frequencies and
pretend it's a sound it's not a sound
but pretend it's a sound and convert it
into sound and say what would the
gravitational wave sound like if it were
a sound and this is what it sounds like
it sounds like a birds chirp which is
not quite what you heard but that's how
it came out my mouth but can't see one
question on that one question that so
it's laudable to be clear on that but
just to also because if our eardrums
were able to vibrate via the
gravitational wave influence if if them
that is what we would kind of if there
is one distinction okay if I may that
it's not a transverse wave and Excise
so sound waves are transverse waves so
the oscillation is along the direction
of propagation gravitational waves and
electromagnetic waves oscillate
perpendicular to the direction of
propagation right and that kind of has
it's important for how it affects our
geology
okay so if we go back to the image up
there the oscillation that we measure
how the mirrors at the end of that
l-shape telescope are being displaced
are basically recorded by the scribble
we can see at the bottom of each banana
the two graphs are what we measured at
the two different detectors a Hanford in
Washington Livingston in Louisiana so we
had the signal was detected
independently in the two detectors at
the same time with only a slight time
delay as I said and what you see in the
signal the real data is the scribble so
we see that the oscillation of the
mirrors increase as time progressed the
duration the axis under that scribble is
not shown but the duration is those
point two seconds the amplitude went up
as you can see and eventually I'm sorry
I'm following my vision but I should you
know it's in your direction it's this
way it went up and then it went down and
petered off that's when the two black
holes came together formed a stable
black hole and then there were no more
gravitational waves all right so that's
one thing the amplitude went up the
sound you hear becomes louder before it
dies off the second thing is that the
peaks of each oscillation come closer
and closer together that means the
frequency of the oscillation is
increasing and that's the pitch of the
sound is becoming higher and higher so
that's the chirp great so that's what we
call a gravitational wave chirp the
banana you see is another way of
the exact same phenomenon the banana
gets brighter
that's the amplitude of the stretching
becomes stronger and stronger and the
frequency again if I may turn my back
momentarily to you the frequency goes up
as a function of time and that's how you
get that curvature and the closer the
two black holes are coming together
the faster the frequency goes up until
it dies off because you form the single
black hole right all right now now I'm
gonna finish by coming back to your
initial question what we measure is the
amplitude of the wave the frequency of
the wave and the fact that that
frequency of the gravitational wave is
changing as a function of time so we're
measuring a frequency derivative these
three pieces of information are encoding
the masses of the two black holes and
how far away this system was so that's
how by studying that progression that
scribble as I call it and comparing it
to templates we have from Einstein's
theory to talk about it tell us about
those what are the templates the
templates are basically if we take if we
take on Stein's theory of general
relativity and ask ourselves if two
black holes are at some distance and we
follow space-time and we solve with
general activity equations the change in
space-time as the two black holes are
moving as the eggbeater is messing up
space-time around them we can calculate
what is the amplitude the frequency and
the frequency pollution with time of the
gravitational waves being produced
calculate with computers so
supercomputers in fact because this
calculation this simulation is very very
hard tough to do and you need
supercomputers to do it and some of
these simulations may run even four
months at the time
so but but we have we the Royal way this
is actually not my own personal work but
relativities have been able to do these
simulations for about a little over 10
years now so we can create templates of
these kinds of signals and when we
correlate them with our data from the
detector we can then find the best
fitting template that then tells us that
that particular signal came from a pair
of black holes that is that far away in
the masses in this particular case was
about 20 or 30 solar masses plus or
minus of course there's always errors in
every measurement we make so that that
was a twenty fifth twenty twenty sixteen
so there have been discoveries since he
give us a sense of what's been going on
the last couple years yes so since that
first one that shook our world and and
honestly it shook it shook humanity if I
may say because we on that day of the
announcement we were media people at all
the universities did the count not
ourselves but on that one day we were on
front covers more than 900 newspaper
front covers across the whole world
almost as much as trauma okay yeah so
then after that up until now we have
announced another five or so more
collisions of black holes that we have
detected in our data and another third
gravitational wave detector in Italy has
joined operations so now there is more
confirmation of more of these events
independent confirmation and now we're
discovering a population of binary black
holes in the universe now you've also
gonna be on black exactly and that has
made again that sort of them the second
most significant detection which is two
neutron stars
details for the neutron star yes and
we're gonna we're gonna I'm gonna tell
you what a neutron studies and and have
you all in New York look at the Chicago
skyline since northwestern is in Chicago
so so this is actually this is to scale
unlike his movie so this is the Chicago
skyline so a big city you know about ten
miles across and the shadow you see
hanging above the Chicago skyline is the
edge of a neutron star to scale now a
neutron star is the death remnant of a
star that may be ten times the mass of a
Sun we end up forming when it runs out
of nuclear fuel so it will form it will
be about the the death remnant will be
about one-and-a-half times the mass of
the Sun and it will be about as big as a
big city downtown okay that's roughly
the scale you can imagine how big the
circle is thankfully no neutron star is
hanging above Chicago now as we speak
or above New York City but that gives
you some sense so and our second biggest
discovery which reached us on August 17
2017 so we're approaching the one-year
anniversary soon I was right around the
clip that was another memorable day of
course for many of us so it was just a
few days before the Eclipse now it used
to be that the big event of that month
was gonna be the Eclipse and if this had
not happened I would remember the date
of the Eclipse but right now I forgot
the day thank you because of what I
remember is August 17th so two neutron
stars came together in a similar fashion
the the to neutral cells came together
and we got another banana a
we this time we had three detectors so
you see again Hanford Livingston and we
had the Italian detector operating as
well and we saw the two bananas in the
two detectors the scale you see the
signal duration is much longer it's no
longer just a fraction of a second what
you see on the screen is about 30
seconds but actually in our data this is
what you see visually here but in our
data we extracted the the signal lasted
a hundred and forty seconds so a couple
of minutes a really long signal which
tells us that the masses that came
together in this death spiral were
actually much smaller right so about an
one and a half solar mass as opposed to
thirty years as opposed to certainly so
the lower the mass the longer the signal
the longer this death spiral lasts
now the third detector doesn't show a
banana partly because the third detector
is not as sensitive and partly because
it was at a very special location on the
sky that they said detector didn't have
good visibility let's say and then and
then spectacular things happened after
the collision of the two neutron stars
unlike two black holes which come
together in peace form a single black
hole and nothing else happens after that
two neutron stars actually give us a
whole set of fireworks in
electromagnetic waves so you could
actually not only see them in
gravitational waves you can see them yes
you can see them in light real light and
that started a whole other type of
astronomy multi messenger astronomy
multi messenger meaning two types of
waves came out of the same source
gravitational waves and electromagnetic
waves and what what have people learned
from the neutron star collision there's
a lot of talk about new ways of thinking
about nuclear astrophysics yes so we
learned a couple of different things so
first of all in the electric learn
things up from this multi messenger
character
the source so one thing is that the
first thing we saw in electromagnetic
waves was a gamma ray signal this is the
highest frequency electromagnetic waves
we can detect and we knew gamma ray
short bursts of gamma rays existed we
had detected them for many years since
the late 60s but and we had hypothesized
that maybe mergers of neutron stars were
responsible for them but we had no proof
the proof came from the gravitational
waves because only in the gravitational
waves we can measure masses so the
measurement that chirped the banana
tells us that it was two neutron stars
that collided so we've associated with
for the first time we had proved that
two neutron stars collide can give you a
gamma-ray burst burst so that multi
messengered combination proved the
origin of short gamma-ray bursts are due
to neutron star collisions that was one
big the second was that the two neutron
stars came together and as the neutrons
collided they actually formed the
heaviest elements we know on earth so
elements like gold and platinum a lot
heavier than iron we of course know they
exist we have them on our planet we have
them you know on our rings and earrings
or whatever my wedding ring so I used to
have one of those she does it's a bit of
a sore point but let's move on okay so
so we know they exist but but actually
astrophysically or physically we didn't
know for sure how they are formed they
are not formed in the Centers of stars
that we knew and through nuclear
reactions so a hypothesis was maybe
there formed in neutron star collisions
with this one event from August 17th
we got experimental proof through with
the electromagnetic waves and
gravitational waves telling us
two new trousers collided we have now
proved that gold was formed at this one
event and therefore we solve that
mystery as well that's fantastic
congratulations well I take credit not
just myself but there's a whole
collaboration of hundreds of scientists
absolutely so we're reaching the end of
our segment but there's one other
question or maybe one and a half
questions so have you received any data
that doesn't fit the templates or more
generally have how can you imagine
testing Einstein's general relativity in
this extreme environment using
gravitational waves we always try to
test Einstein yep okay we push that
frontier
he made I mean his theory must break
down at some point because it involves
the singularity at the center of the
black hole and we don't like that that's
what the Masters break exactly that's
where the division by zero doesn't make
sense so somewhere general activity has
to break down with gravitational wave
observations we are observing black
holes moving at half the speed of light
60% of the speed of light this is the
strongest regime of gravity we have ever
probed with anything nothing else has
probed that regime so so far we have not
seen anything in the gravitational wave
data that disagrees with general
relativity but we keep pushing that
frontier and maybe one day we'll see
something so it's always at the back of
our minds and would you say that sort of
would be the culmination of this
enterprise - to push the understanding
of gravity to the next place the
physicists in me might say that so
that's always something we try to keep
testing that theory the astrophysicist
in me wants to know about these black
holes and neutron stars how do they form
what's their masses how can nature form
these pairs of black holes and neutron
stars in such high numbers that we see
so many of them right so this is what
we're after
on the astrophysics side well good
luck with all those fantastically
interesting projects and everybody
please join me in thanking Vicki
Calogero
[Applause]
and talking about talking about black
holes of course Stephen Hawking is the
great scientist who comes to mind and
this to think all of you no doubt know
sadly Stephen Hawking passed away this
year so I'd like to spend a little bit
of time thinking about what it is that
Hawking told us about black holes what
were the insights that he gave us and
what puzzles emerged from his work that
we are still struggling to resolve and
probably will continue to struggle with
for some time and toward that end as a
little bit of background we need to have
some understanding of a concept that
everybody is familiar with at some level
or another but let's use this
opportunity to get us all in the same
place and that's the concept of entropy
so entropy is a word that's freely used
in the culture we often use it to
describe a certain amount of going from
order to disorder that's going from low
entropy to high entropy that's sort of
the intuition that the culture has about
this word so let's start with that very
basic way of thinking about entropy and
a good example would be let's say I take
my book I throw it up in the air it
starts very ordered all the pages were
in complete numerical order but as they
come down it's overwhelmingly likely
that they will not ant land in numerical
order they'll land in a highly
disordered state and that gives you some
sense of what it means to go from an
ordered arrangement to a highly
disordered arrangement going from low
entropy to higher entropy now of course
that's just a sort of fanciful everyday
example if we had more toward a physics
example we could imagine having a box of
gas and imagine it just has a small
number of atoms in there and imagine
that they're all neatly arranged in this
nice cubic lattice this would be a very
ordered or low entropy configuration of
the gas like the pages all in numerical
order now contrast that with a box of
gas that has
a whole lot of atoms a whole lot of
particles are all bouncing around in a
completely haphazard way this would be a
very disordered state a high entropy
state and another way of thinking about
the distinction between low entropy and
high entropy which will be use of in
just a moment is the amount of
information that would be required to
describe these two configurations
because look on the left you don't need
a lot of data it's a cubic lattice
you've got 3 by 3 by 3 atoms filling out
that lattice and if I give you the
separation of them say 10 centimeters
that basically describes the
configuration on the left you don't need
a lot of information to describe a
system that has low entropy but let's
say I wanted to describe the
configuration on the right well I
basically have to tell you where each
and every particle is located that's the
only way I could describe and look at
all the information I need to describe
that configuration so the idea is low
entropy not a lot of information high
entropy takes a lot of information
that's hidden in this configuration of
particles and that's kind of the
distinction between order disorder low
in to behind your P low information high
information now of course I'm talking in
loose language so that we can all get a
feel for the critical ideas but you can
make this all quite precise and this
gentleman over here you know who this is
who's this Ludwig Boltzmann that's right
and this is his his famous tombstone and
you see that formula on the top of his
tombstone and that is the formula that
makes these statements precise this is a
formula that you learn if you take a
course in statistical mechanics
thermodynamics S stands for entropy K is
Boltzmann's constant and the rest of it
has to do with the number of
configuration of the ingredients of the
particles that make up the system and
the famous second law of thermodynamics
makes use of this formula and again it's
something that we're quite familiar with
in the culture that things typically go
as I said from low entropy to high
that's the natural progression of a
system which means that this quantity s
tends to increase over time the entropy
later on is almost always greater than
the entropy earlier on in the evolution
of a system and what we'd like to do now
is have this idea come into contact with
the idea of black holes and we'll see
that there's a certain kind of tension
that arises it's a very fruitful tension
that will take our understanding further
as we try to come to grips with it and
to help us go on that journey we're
going to now bring out the donner
professor of science and the department
of physics at Harvard whose primary area
of research is string theory he's
received numerous awards and
recognitions for his work including the
Dirac Medal and the breakthrough prize
please welcome qumran bhava
[Music]
now I should say that I have known this
gentleman for over thirty years we were
I guess both postdocs at Harvard in the
1980s you you got a job at Harvard as
faculty but that's okay we're still were
still you're still a good you're doing
very well today thank you and and I
should say my most exciting intellectual
adventures in string theory have been
the papers that we have done together so
there's a lot of fun with you Brian
thank you so it's been an honor to work
with you so thank you so so let's let's
now get into this subject here we heard
a little bit about entropy and about the
second law that entropy increases over
time but in the 1970s people like
bekenstein and Hawking and I think we
have some pictures of these folks that
can come up on the screen they began to
worry about how the second law of
thermodynamics would behave in the
environment of a black low so you give
us a sense of what they were puzzling
about so parts of the puzzle was the
objects they knew falls into the black
holes but they cannot come out so
objects that are falling in have entropy
just like what Brian already described
you have some information about where
they are how they are but once you fall
into the black hole then you don't have
anymore access to that information so
what happened to that information so
that seems like you lost entropy entropy
went down and that's against what
Boltzmann said so can I give a concrete
example of that so I think we have a
little silly example if I took my wallet
it has information it has entropy I
throw it into the black hole and you're
asking what happened to that entropy did
it disappear from the universe exactly
so that was the kind of question that
they were struggling to understand how
could this be consistent right so they
began thinking about this and then there
are a few ideas that they were thinking
about and in particular the properties
of the horizon of a black hole the edge
the edge the event horizon that without
the edge in which beyond which you can
no lie
can escape they found it had some
interesting properties and in particular
they began studying what is the area
what is the area of this edge and how
does it change and in particular what
happens if you throw objects into this
yep black hole what happens with this
area yeah and one of the surprising
things I found was that when you throw
objects in this area cannot stay put and
in fact increases yep
so they began to think about okay what
could this mean about this
what what this could be related in some
way compensated by the fact that you're
losing something the entropy could it be
somehow compensated by the fact that
this area is growing so they begin to
ask the question could the area of this
event horizon be in any way related to
the lost entropy so we actually can
unpack that so let's just go through a
couple of little examples here so this
is the standard second law of
thermodynamics the entropy grows over
time let's just take the two boxes that
I started with to illustrate what you're
describing if we take those two boxes
and we put them together what happens to
the entry it goes up right Boltzmann's
right so we have the combined entropy is
greater than the individuals entropy now
you're describing something that doesn't
have to do with gas in a box you're
talking about the geometry of a black
hole so for example they studied what
happens if you study one black hole with
one area of event horizon and another
black hole with a different area and you
bring them together you merge them and
you get a new black hole with a new area
and they found that the area of the new
formed black hole is bigger than the sum
of the two areas just like the entropy
had that property the entropy resulting
on the box when you combine them was
bigger than the individual entropy so
the entropy sounded very similar to the
area or area sounded very similar to the
entropy so they began asking could it be
that the area and entropy are
proportional to one another for black
holes and indeed they found a formula
that we can bring
up here so entropy is the area and the
proportionality constant is a little bit
complicated before to you right because
you don't really have to worry too much
about that this number on the right hand
side but the basic lesson is that
they're guessing they're they're
suggesting that the area of the event
horizon is somehow holding on to the
entropy holding on to the information in
some sense that's inside the black hole
now you gave an interesting thought
experiment about how to test that you
were talking about throwing something in
and and watching the area and it just so
happens then we have a little little
segment on that here so why don't we go
through that so here's a so take us so
what are we seeing here and then we'll
do your little thought experiment yeah I
guess we are seeing a black hole a red
black hole yes exactly with the event
horizon of it you can see that the idea
that the information is proportional to
the area with some proportionality
constant if each individual element of
the information is like one square there
we just divided this sphere into this
area so these represent bits of
information on that surface of that
black hole so those little squares can
roughly speaking me thought of as Planck
areas these in the Planck length that
describe sort of the smallest length
that makes sense in a in a quantum
theory of gravity squares of the size 10
to the minus 33 centimeters or so if you
want to tend 7/10 or my 30 days squared
yeah each size of the squares yep so you
basically count the number of those
little squares that are on the event
horizon and that's the amount of entropy
it has so if we now talk if this is true
and we were to take a particle that sort
of carried one unit of entropy what
would we expect to happen if this is
true we expect this area to grow exactly
by one square so let's let's sort of do
that we have this is actually a real
real film of space here so so let's get
our our particle going in to this guy
over here oh and it's and it's kind of
interesting
stroboscopic effect there but so so
let's
good so the one on the left was the
original black hold the one on the right
is a larger one after a particle has
fallen in so if we take all those little
squares and we smear them out on the
larger black hole what we'd expect to
happen is something like that
exactly so one one more square so we
throw a sort of one particle in that
carries one unit of disorder and the
black hole eats it it grows a little bit
and in fact you can calculate that the
amount by which it will expand can
accommodate one more of these little
tiles and that makes this a consistent
way of thinking about black holes so so
this was like an important happening how
important was was this kind of an
insight well it was the amazing insight
because it was the first time where
Einstein's theory of relativity was
combined with quantum effects and that
is what Hawking used to actually argue
that the entropy of a black hole has
something to do with the area and so
this combination of quantum theory and
Einstein's theory was quite novel and
this was in early seventies mid
seventies so is this the end of this
story when it comes to entropy and black
holes like what what what issues does
this leave over
well actually the problem was that
Hawking's argument showed that there
must be information but on the other
hand the horizon of a black hole is
featureless so you don't see these point
squares or anything so there seems to be
no room for information to be stored on
it so in fact if you use Einstein's
equations and solve it you find there is
exactly one solution for a spherical
symmetric black hole one solution means
it has zero entropy it's exactly ordered
state there's no choice one piece of
information one piece of information and
that is inconsistent with what Hawking
found when he combined Einstein's theory
of quantum mechanics where he found a
huge amount of information and the
question is where is this huge amount of
information stored is it the shape of
the horizon or is it what aspect of
black hole encodes the microscopic
scarred structure of the black hole that
was open when Hawking discovered this
fact so so for Hawking's idea to work
let's just go back to my little example
of sort of throwing the wallet in so so
in that little example I threw the
wallet and we said where did the
information go so so the new idea if
it's true would be I take my wallet and
I throw it in and rather than it like
disappearing the idea roughly speaking
would be the information that is in my
wallet the configuration of all the
atoms and molecules it goes toward the
black hole and we want it to be the case
of that information kind of like smears
itself out on the outside and is encoded
in sort of bits ones and zeros that's a
picture that's the picture and principle
we're this true I could actually extract
that information in principle and use it
to rebuild anything that thrillin in
this case it would be my wallet so
that's yeah that's if the information is
not lost that information is there
that's what we would expect right yes
that's the hope and the puzzle is is
that out is that actually true and how
do you actually see this information
where is it stored or how do you account
for the microstates yes of the black
hole or the entropy of the black hole
and that's where you come in well me and
my colleagues in string theory began
studying these questions more seriously
with the advent of duality symmetries in
string theory
so first exactly where to drink there I
should say a few words about string
theory so string theory is is the
framework where we believe combines
Einstein's theory of relativity with
quantum theory in a consistent framework
and as part of it it demands that the
entities making of the matter is not are
not just point particles but entities
like strings or membranes or extended
objects have to play a key role and so
that's one aspect of string theories a
little if you want to take us through
this is just a little example what
string theory might look like so you got
a piece of matter and we're gonna dive
into it and then you're saying that if
we go sufficiently you go to the
beginning inside you'll see the atoms
first and you know inside the atoms you
see the the nucleus and the nucleus you
see well here I guess the protons and
neutrons okay and you go inside them
see the Cork's and once you see the
course you can go inside them and if you
zoom in that's the further you might see
actually that these featureless quarks
that you think are point particle
actually they are tiny strings vibrating
strings of some sort and that's the kind
of a picture that we expect to be true
in the context of string theory that
point particles are point like because
we are not zoomed in sufficiently close
to them and if you zoom in enough they
will have features like strings how big
with those we don't know exactly but it
could be like 10 to the minus 30
centimeters somewhat close to the Planck
scale that we discussed already in the
context of the areas of the horizon of
the black hole so that's the basic
feature of string theory but as one of
the aspects of string theory that was
originally one of the negative features
was that string theory predicted that
the spatial dimension of the universe is
not three and that was manifested in
contradiction with the fact that we
think we live in three spatial
dimensions we have three spatial
dimensions string theory seemed to
demand that we have nine spatial
dimensions and so this was a
contradiction originally and physicists
thought how could this possibly work and
one resolution was oh these extra six
extra dimensions that we have are so
tiny like little circles at every point
in space let's imagine six dimensions at
each point six types of circles which
are so tiny that you cannot see so the
idea would be the macroscopic dimensions
are only three the big ones are three
but the tiny ones are six and the tiny
ones are hard to see unless you really
zoom in and that's difficult to do with
the energies that's available to us in
our experiments today so actually I
don't know if you guys can can grab it
but there is a little video that we had
tacked on there with the skyscrapers if
you can bring it up to to show this idea
of extra dimensions great if you can't
get to it then that's okay too
but the idea would be that you've got
these these big dimensions that we know
about these extra dimensions and then
how do you relate this to this idea of
black hole so this was actually a
negative feature for string theory so
string theorists were kind of struggling
yeah we have these six extra dimensions
it's a little embarrassing it's tiny you
don't see them
and then other people said sure sure yes
yes so this was the state-of-the-art
till mid 90s and where we didn't know
what to do with these extra dimensions
they were there just to make the theory
consistent and we were hiding it away in
tiny little things and then came the
question about the black holes and the
black hole had the opposite problem the
problem with the black hole was we were
missing information of the black holes
where were they what were that
information it turned out that these two
problems cancelled each other out and so
this is the problem that was very are
they in where are the ingredients or the
degrees of freedom that constitutes
black hole ended up in the internal
spatial tiny spatial things that I was
talking about so extra dimensions were
helpful in finding the resolution and
perhaps we can see there yeah so can we
actually skip the next one and go one
beyond where we can see the perfect
thank you so as you can see here the the
red doughnut shaped object there is to
represent these tiny internal dimensions
and the blue sheet that you see
represents the macroscopic three
macroscopic dimensions and so the idea
there is that if you take a string or a
membrane or one of these extended
objects and wrap it around the cycles on
these external tiny spaces like a torus
or like a circle or doughnut or whatnot
shape you have it will create a mass at
the point where you're wrapping around
that circle and the more it wraps around
the more mass is going to be
constituting there and the more its
gonna shape and distort the geometry of
space around it and it is enough of it
it's going to create this warped space
which is what we call the black hole so
the black hole itself can be viewed as
these strings or membranes wrapped
around these extra cycles of this tiny
space and so then that if the question
is what accounts for the degrees of
freedom of the black hole it are these
are precisely these strings or membranes
wrapped around these extra dimensions
how many are there how many degrees of
freedom are there what are they
entropy gets translated to how many ways
these extra strings or membranes can
wrap around these extra dimensions and
there are many ways and that accounted
for the entropy of the black hole so
with anteye anteye straw meter and I did
actually computation of how much entropy
is there in these wrappings of the
string around a around the external
around these internal dimensions of
string theory and we found exact match
with the prediction that Pickens Stein
and Hawking had made about the entropy
of these black holes so just to quickly
unpack a little bit so so basically you
found a new way of describing black
holes in string theory which makes use
of the extra curled up dimensions the
red part of this image that we find here
and you're saying that by wrapping these
strings or ingredients of string theory
around the extra dimensions you can
create a warping in space that looks
just like the black hole that we've been
talking about for many years before
string theory even was on anybody's mind
but in this description you can do a
direct count of the amount of
information necessary to describe the
situation and bang on it matches what
Hawking's exact said yes so so this
gives us insight into one possible way
of describing the internal structure of
a black hole which in many ways I think
the community of uses is one of the most
important pieces of data that string
theory may be going in the right
direction we don't have experimental
support for these ideas but here's a
mathematical piece of experimental
support if you will that it matches
ideas that have been on the table for
25-30 years
so so this isn't a key step forward but
now let's turn to some of the puzzles
that still yes remain and and part of
the puzzles surround something that's
tightly related to what we've been
talking about which is something called
Hawking radiation if you just tell us a
bit about what Hawking radiation is so
Hawking after discovering the properties
of having information the backhaul and
the entropy he also noticed that the
black holes actually are not quite black
and what happens
is that if we go to the next perhaps yet
PowerPoint so if you if you go near get
up to the next one if you go near the
event horizon of the black hole yep so
what happens is that you get pairs of
particles created out of vacuum these
are quantum fluctuations the quantum
fluctuation is always creating particles
and antiparticles in pairs on typically
they go in and out without doing
anything but if they are near the event
horizon one of them perchance could go
towards the inside of the black hole and
then one of them could go outside and
the mum which goes inside has no way of
getting out so stuck there but the one
going outside can leave and go far away
from it all the way to infinity and that
looks like a radiation from the
viewpoint of some of the outside so in
other words from the viewpoint of some
of the outside the black hole is
actually radiating energy as it radiates
energy it loses mass and it shrinks and
shrinks and shrinks until after a while
the black hole totally disappears where
there's no more energy left to emit so
once the once the black hole disappears
the question is what happens to all that
information that went into the black
hole what happened to that area was
talking about where is that information
gone so this was a question that Hawking
basically posed and this was the
probably the slide previous to this one
yeah we can go back if you wait two
slides if you would so if you if you saw
that two slides actually you know
further back sorry two is the wrong
number go back to the court of Hawking
if you would so so he had this amazing
coat if you if you perhaps you recall
the discussion between Einstein and Bohr
that Einstein did not like the
probabilistic aspect of quantum
mechanics and so he said God does not
play dice and Niels Bohr responded by
saying to Einstein stop telling god what
to do
and hawking added his own wrinkle on
this he said well what happens if you
throw a dice inside the black hole and
the black hole after white disappears
and we did disappears the dice so and
then he said not only does God throw
dice he sometimes throws it throws them
where they cannot be seen and then you
made a little little cake so yeah we had
we had the lucky occasion of having
Stephen Hawking as our guest at home a
couple years ago when he was visiting
Harvard and we made the cake in the form
of a black hole with the dice and the
book his famous book which is actually
made of is a cake and it's actually
gluten-free because he was allergic so
so so Steven had had his cake and it
could either - yeah so in that in that
picture you see that there are two two
dice hanging there floating towards the
black hole and it's going in and that's
the issue of the information puzzle you
lose the information of what what is the
dice roll and that's what's called the
information puzzle because if the dice
rolls some number and the black hole
evaporates and disappears we did this
appears the information about what the
role of the dice was and that's called
the information puzzle which we still
are struggling to understand even today
now most people in in the field for a
long time have anticipated that somehow
the information does get out with that
radiation that we saw coming off of the
black hole now for a while Stephen
Hawking said that the information would
would not come and I mean that quote was
quite serious he was saying that we have
to rethink quantum mechanics because the
information does not come back out he
then changed his mind on that yes so
part of the reason for this is the
discovery of a more detailed version on
what is called holography in other words
this this began with the work already
back in the in the long time ago but
became more precise with the work of war
mother Senna where it was discovered hub
that you can describe a gravitational
system precisely using objects which are
much simpler to understand
and in particular in that system you
could prove mathematically rigorously
there's no way you can lose information
so therefore indirectly there was a
proof that whatever happens to black
holes the information should get out so
that part was kind of beginning to be
established using these kind of
arguments in string theory but the
wrinkle is that even though there's this
mathematical proof that this should
happen we still did not know exactly how
and some people thought maybe the
information gets out with this radiation
as you were saying right very gradually
and very tiny bit at a time but
gradually builds off to give you
information out and this is what in the
early 2000s I believe Stephen agreed
that this is the resolution but I still
think and we I think the community still
believes we haven't really understood
how this happens exactly so the
information puzzle about how this
information comes out is still one of
the big mysteries of black holes and we
don't really understand it so do you
think it's possible that we will one day
conclude that the original view of
Hawking was right that the information
does not get out is that still on the
table in your view well I think it
sounds much less likely given that we
think we understand a dual description
another description of these black holes
so it seems like that seems much less
likely now but you know we can never say
we know everything about the subject
that's our current understanding it
because of course evolve but but even
even with that understanding it's not
our understanding is not sufficiently
detailed to convince us of this of how
it happens now a lot of our discussion
here has been focusing on what happens
at the edge of a black lot the event
horizon or black hole that it may be
where the information stored it may be
where the entropy is stored we haven't
said much about what happens at the
center right can we just spend a little
time talking about that well one of the
things that happens in the center of the
black hole is that there's this
singularity this infinity that Brian
discussed already this is this division
by zero analogy and we don't believe
that's physical we believe that's just
the phantom of our equation it's just
the mathematical thing that comes out
and that means that our description
breaks down not that there is an
infinity now quickly the infinity
could be physically that you've got all
this mass crushed to zero size and that
size is not physically up for us there's
nothing smaller than planks length which
is about 10 to minus 33 saying there's
the notion of space breaks down anything
smaller than that so there cannot be an
infinity in physics we don't believe so
so we don't understand what is happening
at that at that at that in that way and
the understanding of this singularity we
are not at all close to understanding
what's happening there we know that
there should be a good description but
we don't have it and why that's
important is that well we want to know
what's happening inside the black holes
of course we can send somebody and find
out what happens to that infinity but
that would not be a fair thing and even
if we did that even if we said well we'd
send some creature not not us that robot
or something the robot cannot come back
to tell us what happened or what they
saw so because nothing can scape from
black holes so it won't be useful so we
have to figure that without going inside
the black hole what's going on there and
that's still we have no not only we
don't have observational data we won't
we don't have enough theoretical
understanding and we think it's
important not just for the black holes
but it turns out that those infinities
that we see if you try to pass through
those infinities to the other side so to
speak it turns out it looks very much
like the infinities we see at the
beginning of our own universe it is as
if our universe is emerging from inside
one of these black holes along those
lines and don't lose your train of
thought there oftentimes people think of
the center of the black hole as a
location in space the center is that the
right way no actually it's like in a
given time it happens at a given time
and that's because the nature of space
on time changes as you enter the black
hole but we need cross the event horizon
of the black so one of the reasons why
you can't get out is because you can't
stop time from ticking forward exactly
so going forward in forward in time it's
like going closer and closer to distinct
there and then at certain time you hit
the singularity that's the time it's at
the given time is that the singularity
could be the end of time in some sense
it could be but we don't believe that
and then so what you would say what's
the after that and that looks very much
like what could be a new universe or
something so so we are interested in
understanding the
resolution to the issue of singularity
of black holes and I think it's very
exciting we know that black holes as we
discussed already in this program there
are a huge amount of evidence that they
exist so they are there we cannot say
we're just imagining so what is that
what is that singularity what are we
learning from it it's one of the most
beautiful mysterious objects I think in
the universe and hopefully by some
experiments and maybe by some
theoretical understanding we'll have
some progress in that so what's your
guess I mean if we come back and we
invite you back further I don't know the
2025 world science festival can you give
us the answer to what happens at the
center of a black hole
maybe you inviting 20 55 million 20 50
all right good good prediction a safe
prediction please join me in thanking
Qumran Vasa thank you thank you very
much fantastic good night everybody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]